Memorial Day Weekend a great time to
save on certain items but not everything
is at its best deal price right now in
today's eight on your side what you want
to buy now buy later and how to save
even more historically Memorial Day has
offered big savings on major house
appliances consumer savings expert
Andrea warrock says may is Maytag month
she's seeing up to 30 percent off major
home appliances from stores like Lowe's
Home Depot Best Buy and other Appliance
retailers selling Maytag rebates when
buying three select appliances here's
how to save even more you also want to
inquire about maybe free delivery look
at the floor models sometimes you can
save more with that and then ask about
financing deals another big ticket item
mattresses she says right now you can
save up to 40 to 60 percent off quality
mattresses so for instance Safta was
offering 325 off their Loom and leaf
memory foam mattress and at Mattress
Firm you're looking at 53 percent off
the Beautyrest plush pillow top mattress
car deals coming back to Auto Lots with
Memorial Day promising savings on both
financial and lease options retailers
offering big price cuts on home
furniture as well keep an eye out for
sales from Wayfair West Elm Pottery Barn
and Ashley as for clothing major
clearance deals up to 75 off of winter
and spring right now but avoid buying
summer clothing or outdoor entertaining
Essentials right now as they are at
their Peak price and hold off on
electronics and laptops electronics are
going to be a better buy during Amazon's
Prime day which at this point is just
several weeks away predictions say it's
going to hit around mid-july and we also
know that competitor stores like Walmart
Target and Best Buy will be hosting
their own sales around this time
she's so great isn't she and here's how
to save even more find coupons at sites
like coupon cabin which organize
Memorial Day deals all in one place
offering coupons for instance like 40
off at Macy's and 40 off at Gap I was
curious when you get a laptop and then
she answered it she said mid-july Amazon
Prime day so wait
standing by